Die Operation, die die Ärzte an der Johns
Hopkins Universität in Baltimore in den USA
durchgeführt haben, hat weltweit Schlagzeilen
gemacht.
In einer 14-stündigen Operation haben die
Mediziner erstmals einen Penis mitsamt Hodensack
transplantiert.
Empfänger war ein US-Soldat, der in Afghanistan
verletzt worden war.
Der Penis und der Hodensack stammten von einem
verstorbenen Spender.
Den Eingriff führte ein Team aus neun Chirurgen
und zwei Urologen bereits am 26.
März aus.
Der schwierigste Teil der Operation war dabei,
zahlreiche Arterien und Venen miteinander
zu verbinden.
Die Transplantation solle dem jungen Soldaten
helfen, wieder ein normales Leben zu führen,
sagt der Direktor für plastische Chirurgie
an der Johns Hopkins Universität, Dr.
Andrew Lee:
"Wir glauben, dass es bisher ein Erfolg ist.
Allerdings war die Operation erst Ende März.
Es ist also noch sehr früh.
Wir erwarten, dass der Patient das Krankenhaus
in dieser Woche verlassen kann.
Eine Wiederkehr der Funktionen kann aber dauern,
das gilt sowohl für das Urinieren als auch
für die Sexual-Funktionen.
Nerven wachsen sehr langsam, deshalb kann
es viele Monate dauern, bis einige Funktionen
zurückkehren."
Der operierte Soldat gab eine kurze schriftliche
Erklärung ab.
Als er aufgewacht sei, hab er sich endlich
wieder normal gefühlt.
Das sei typisch, sagt Dr.
Lee: "Viele verletzte Veteranen haben gesagt, dass
sie sich nicht mehr ganz fühlen, wenn sie
ihre Genitalien teilweise oder ganz verloren
haben.
Deshalb ist das etwas, was ihnen hilft, sich
wieder ganz zu fühlen.
Körperlich, aber auch psychisch.
Wir denken, dass es ihnen hilft, ihre Identität,
ihre Männlichkeit und ihr Selbstbewusstsein
wiederherzustellen.
Das wurde deutlich, als wir mit diesem Patienten
gesprochen haben.
Aber auch bei Gesprächen mit anderen Männern."
Es handelte sich nicht um die erste Penis-Transplantation
weltweit, aber um die erste Verpflanzung eines
Penis mitsamt Hodensack.
Die erste erfolgreiche Penisverpflanzung war
2015 in Südafrika gemeldet worden.